tickets in the same location and date as
each of our victims mr. Miller
coincidence coincidence maybe but it is
gonna be hard for you to explain away
your teeth marks and Tiffany Heights and
writer never matter you just keep
telling yourself then TV dramas like CSI
make forensic detective work look like
it's just about foolproof and it's true
that since the late 1980s DNA analysis
and other forensic tools have helped
both identify the guilty and exonerate
the innocent in cases nationwide but
forensic science is not quite as cut and
dried as it may seem a new report by a
White House advisory council is urging
federal prosecutors and judges to tread
cautiously when dealing with forensic
evidence when the underlying science has
not been proven by testing and research
CBS News justice reporter Paula Reid is
here with more Paula good morning good
morning there's a highly critical report
from the country's top science and
technology experts what were their
biggest concerns I think a lot of people
are going to be very surprised to hear
that this distinguished panel is calling
into question scientific methods that
have been used for decades well to
convict people and to let people go free
their biggest complaint is the way
scientific evidence is essentially
assessed by jurors the judge lets
experts from both sides come up debated
and then the jurors ultimately decide
what is and is not science and this
panel wants that to determine before
this information gets into the courtroom
what are the most common methods that
they're saying we should think twice
about that we all think are without
reproach so to be clear we are not
talking about single source DNA or
fingerprints we saw that those were used
in the bombing investigation just this
last week what they're concerned about
are some of these comparison methods for
example bite mark analysis so if you
have a bite mark on a suspect you take
an imprint victim and compare them under
the assumption that that's a very rare
chance that you would get a bad match
but there they don't think that that's a
scientifically rigorous comparison
they're also very concerned about
firearms analysis this is a big deal for
the federal government because they use
this a lot and this analysis tries to
match ammunition to a specific firearm
based on markings that that specific
firearm made on the ammunition so what
are their specific recommendations then
to agencies that have the oversight in
these kinds of such
they want them to spend a lot of money
to do a lot more research course sounds
reasonable but they're up against some
really powerful interests here law
enforcement is incredibly concerned that
if they go out and they do this research
and it's found that these techniques are
faulty that could put into jeopardy a
lot of convictions are talking about
potentially releasing a percentage of
the prison population they're also up
against expert witnesses big money big
business well to that end there's been
some recommendations for the Justice
Department how have they responded the
Department of Justice the Attorney
General have essentially said thanks but
no thanks they think that this is just
one voice in the room they know that
some of these techniques are
controversial they also believe that
they left out some of the studies in
their analysis and ultimately they think
that they are doing what they should be
doing in in connection with the Supreme
Court has ruled that they should do
which is allow the judges to decide who
gets in the courtroom and then
ultimately let the jury decide what a
science so is this Paul is this
ultimately likely to have any effect on
how cases are tried I'm feeling a lot of
they're going to be a lot of Appeals not
one defense attorney I talked to is not
familiar with this report I think
they're going to try to introduce it now
in trials they're going to try to use it
to appeal previous convictions but again
the system is what it is and there's
very powerful interest to not change the
way things are done so ultimately I
think it's going to be used by a lot of
defense attorneys to question expert
witnesses and to appeal prior
convictions all right Paula Reid thank
you very much